welcome to the program we're going to
cross straight over to the UN in New
York where the Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez is speaking about Sudan let's
listen
together the United Nations the league
of Arab states igad and the European
Union
as well as representatives from a number
of countries that are deeply committed
to solving the crisis
there was a strong consensus on
condemning the ongoing fighting in Sudan
and calling for cessation of hostilities
as an immediate priority I appeal for a
ceasefire to take place for at least
three days marking the Eid al-fitrus
celebrations to allow civilians Trapped
In conflict zones to escape and to seek
medical treatment foods and other
essential supplies
these must be the first step in
providing respite from the fighting and
Paving the way for a permanent and
ceasefire
I have been personally engaged in doing
everything possible to make it happen
the secession of hostilities must be
followed by serious dialogue allowing
for the successful transition starting
with the appointment of a civilian
government
the fighting must stop immediately
I am deeply concerned about the terrible
toll on civilians the appalling
humanitarian situation and the
horrifying prospects of further
escalation
hundreds of people have been killed and
injured fighting in urban areas is
particularly dangerous for civilians
including children who have repeatedly
been forced to shelter in schools and
evacuate from hospitals and the fire
disease completely outrageous
humanitarian oppressions are virtually
impossible warehouses vehicles and other
humanitarian assets have been attacked
looted and seized
targeting humanitarian workers and
assets must end and I remind all parties
of their obligations at the
international law including ensuring
Safety and Security of humanitarian Aid
workers
I'm also extremely worried about the
situation of United Nations personnel
many of whom are trapped in their homes
in areas of active conflicts we are
doing everything in our power to be able
to support them
I will continue to use my good offices
in close coordination with our partners
to establish a ceasefire the escalate
tension and start political talks
the United Nations stands with the
Sudanese people in school support of
their wishes for a peaceful secure
future and the return to the democratic
transition thank you
thank you very much
have come and gone what will the
Catalyst be to ensure that a third
attempt will succeed to aspires two
attempted ceasefires have come and gone
what will the Catalyst be for this third
attempt to succeed I think there is a
strong reason for all
parties to the conflict are Muslim we
are living a very important moment in
the Muslim calendar I think this is the
right moment for a ceasefire to hold and
this is fire is absolutely crucial at
the present moment we have been in
contact with the parties we believe it
is possible but everybody must be United
in putting pressure for the ceasefire to
take effectively place
foreign
Secretary General there making it a very
short brief speech to the Press about
the dialogue that's happened behind
closed doors with various stakeholders
about the ongoing conflict in Sudan
Christian salumi was also listening in
for us and Chris it was very clear that
the U.N Secretary General wants to see a
three-day ceasefire obviously to Mark at
the end of the period of Ramadan and the
start of the Eid holiday but also an
opportunity for all sides to
collectively talk seriously about a
long-term ceasefire and a long-term
peace
that's right he said this is the moment
ahead of the Eid holiday and uh
expressed his hope that the third time
will be a charm that this is the moment
that the ceasefire or at least a
cessation of hostilities will take place
allowing the parties to come together
and have what he described as a serious
dialogue and a return to a a transition
to a civilian-led government the U.N put
a mission in Sudan aiming to do just
that back in June of 2020 and the
Secretary General expressing concern
about U.N employees on the ground in the
country there there are about 400
workers some of them uh Sudanese local
residents and some International staff
as well and he said that many of them
have been unable to leave their homes as
a result of the fighting he's very
concerned about their well-being as well
as the well-being of Sudanese civilians
obviously many of whom were dependent on
International 80 even before the
fighting started to take place he
expressed the hope that the message
coming out of his meeting with various
Regional organizations that includes the
Arab League the African Union the
European Union igad the
intergovernmental Authority on
development all of them taking part in
this dialogue that he just wrapped up in
the last hour so that the message coming
from them was United and strong that
there needed to be a cessation of
hostilities and a return to government
uh to uh civilian government and a
civilian government transition indeed of
course uh Antonio guterres will also be
mindful of the fact that uh Abdul fatah
al-birham the Army Chief has also said
within the last 48 hours that he doesn't
really want outside interference it'd be
interesting to see what he thinks the
role of the UN is because without
outside pressure neither side is going
to put their arms down
yeah that's the trouble for the
International Community here and what
further steps can they take to pressure
the sides to come to the table without
uh being in the cut without having their
own peacekeeping force on the ground
there uh right now we're hearing a
United message and a call for the
military leaders to do the right thing
at this point we don't see any sign of
them taking that message to heart so for
the UN
they are focused on the humanitarian
aspects of the conflict right now the
fact that 39 of 59 hospitals are not
functioning that people are going
without food and water because they
can't leave their homes medical
assistance is not available as well so
the hope is that this proceeds in small
steps that there is a cessation of
hostilities to recognize the holiday
that people can get out of Harm's Way
that International interlocutors can
have more say with the parties on the
ground to try to convince them that
there is another way forward we should
see what happens in the coming hours and
whether there is a cessation of violence
for the moment Kristen salumi at the UN
thank you
now on the ground in Sudan thousands of
people are fleeing the capital car too
there's fighting continues between the
Army and the paramilitary rapid support
forces four ceasefire attempts over six
days have failed to stop the violence
the World Health Organization says
nearly 300 people have been killed and
at least 3 000 injured some cartoon
residents are leaving the capital and
heading south towards Jazeera State
that's believed to be relatively calm
others have traveled North from Khartoum
to River Niles state where there's no
violence being reported there so far
Cartier Lopez has more
close to home
days of fighting have left many Sudanese
desperate and Afraid
thousands of people are leaving cartoon
we were told to get out anyone who is
able to leave but we can't just sit
around we need to make a living the Army
and paramilitary Rapid support for CES
blame one another for breaking several
ceasefires in recent days the streets of
the capital are once again seeing the
effects of conflict a lot of reports and
and pictures from people also there's a
lot of dead bodies in the street so then
that our military and some of them are
civilian some of them got recognized by
the peoples who are there from the
neighborhood but some of them were not
during the lull in gunfire some people
venture out to stock up on food and
water what supplies are limited
the United Nations warns a humanitarian
catastrophe is looming
many of the country's best hospitals are
in Khartoum were the most intense
battles are taking place
there are a few hospitals treating the
injured and the number of doctors is
limited there's a lot of overcrowding
that's even though a lot of wounded
can't make it to the hospitals because
of the fighting
but for some leaving isn't an option at
least not yet
it's also real you see children watching
cartoons at home against a backdrop of
airstrikes I was walking outside with a
friend who's hosting me and we heard the
sound of an attack I asked her if indeed
it was an airstrike and she said calmly
yes it feels strange that people are
growing used to this type of situation
after years of political instability
coups and fighting Sudan was on the
verge of transitioning to a civilian-led
government
those plans are now on hold again
thousands of people leave their homes
and search for safety there are fears of
violence could spread Beyond Sudan's
borders Katya Lopez of the young Al
Jazeera
Morgan has more from cartoon
well people are picking where they are
and listening to friends and relatives
who had been able to make it out of the
capital Khartoum and then deciding
whether it's safe or not we spoke to
somebody one of the residents of Hudson
who was able to leave the capital
yesterday and she said it took her 12
hours to get to medanist City which is
in Jazeera State Jazeera is just about
180 kilometers away from the capital of
Khartoum and normally it would take
about three hours to get to madani but
she said that there were a lot of Rapid
support forces checkpoints that they
were asked for the identities and they
were asked where they were heading now
she was able to get safer to madini but
many of the people who spoke to say that
they saw the rsf Looting people who were
trying to leave the capital that some
cars have been targeted depending on the
type of cars that people are driving and
that some cars have been looted forcing
people to walk on foot to safety people
have picked Jazeera state in the central
part of the country and River Nile state
in the northern part of the country
because it's been relatively safe over
the past few days days but hundreds of
others thousands of others rather are
still trapped especially around the
vicinity of the general command of the
Army Headquarters they've not been able
to get out from since Saturday when the
fighting started many people around the
capital say that the situation has
become untenable they've been out of
water for six days now there's been no
electricity and those who've been
injured could not receive Medical
Treatments and those who have already
been in need of Medical Treatments like
renal dialysis hospitals have gone out
of function so many of them are trying
to look for safer options places where
they can get medical attention and
places where they can get food and water
and survive as fighting ridges on in the
capital
Ryan's idea is a civilian who's been
evacuated twice since the fighting broke
out and joins me now from onderman good
to have you with us on the program it's
not been an easy six days for you and
your family you've had to move a few
times
it's been absolutely rough first I was
in matar which is neighboring the
airport and where they are the street
where the fighting broke and I was home
alone but I'm already desensitized to
bullets so when I had bullets I was like
it's just another day but when the
airstrikes happened uh that's when like
it clicked to me that it's really
serious so I had to take cover and pack
a few things and stay on the ground and
the electricity went out and it was very
traumatizing for me so just the time
explain what goes through your mind when
you decide that you have to move because
obviously you don't do it by yourself
you have to I presume communicate with
friends as to where you go and how you
get there safely so just explain that
Journey for us
um so at first we were trying to contact
the red crescent to like help us out but
obviously that was nearly impossible to
come into the neighborhood of hay and
matar due to the soldiers surrounding it
um so we just decided my neighbors
around me we just decided to risk it and
go with our personal cars outside of the
neighborhood but thankfully we went we
left safely some folks were traumatized
and meet and looted but thankfully we
made it out safely so we had to organize
in the neighborhood group uh to move out
so you decided to make the move but just
before that just explain to us the sort
of neighborhood you were in does it have
any strategic value obviously there's an
airport close by but is there anything
else that would make it a place of
danger
a few fruits behind us uh is where the
damage City the rsf uh located in the
within the neighborhood uh was a few
streets down from us so in usual days is
risky let alone nowadays is
day-to-day is just really struggle in
the neighborhood but
um the past few days it was absolutely
terrifying especially being alone and no
with no electricity or water it was
absolutely terrifying and
having the risk of someone jumping into
or like a house or knocking your door it
was beyond I can't even describe how
terrified that was so you've moved to a
place of safety during that Journey
where you stopped at any check points
where you asked any questions
at the Gate of the neighborhood
um we were searched and a little bit
traumatized
um but would they let us go thankfully
we went to cartoon two and I'm even more
blessed that the house that we went to I
don't even know them they're they're
strangers but they're family now to me
because of how they
hosted me and kept me safe also there
was a lack of electricity but thankfully
they have a generator yeah which they
open so we could charge our electronics
and they could pump use the water pump
so there's water available right I spoke
to another lady just a short time ago
and she talked about forces at
checkpoints being very
um polite and respectful uh when people
were going through those checkpoints you
just described those individuals as they
were they the military or were they the
rsf I mean what's your impression of who
is actually monitoring and policing
these routes
uh the first checkpoint was to ask rsf
on
we made our safely thankfully
okay we'll leave it there for now it's
been good to speak to you and uh all
being well we'll check in with you we'll
check in with you again I'm sure very
soon just take care thank you very much
all right thank you very much
in cartoon essential supplies are
running low and basic services like
electricity have been cut Muhammad
al-time has more
people in Khartoum say they are running
out of food and other basic items
confrontations between the Sudanese Army
and the rapid support forces has
prevented the Rahman family from going
outside
there's been a severe shortage of food
and supplies for some time there is a
lack of basic necessities
Sarah says worries about what they'll
eat and drink are overshadowed by her
children's fear
we no longer sleep peacefully my
children ask me hundreds of questions
about the current situation and I don't
have the answers especially my little
boy he panics and gets scared when he
hears the sound of bullets and shooting
sorrow's eldest son remembers when he
first heard the gunfire he was at school
writing an exam the sound ruined his
hopes of celebrating
I was looking forward to spending Eid
happily with my family but when this
fighting happened it has disrupted all
our plans
the house is in darkness electricity
have been cut
everything that is happening to us is
decided by Allah we will try to stock up
on supplies for a month or two hoping
that things will improve the family is
hoping the two sides will stop fighting
and resort to dialogue to resolve the
situation
we pray to Allah Almighty that the
fighting will stop and we appeal to all
parties to stop this war
the city is paralyzed shops and
businesses are closed especially on the
main roads where much of the fighting is
happening
all people can do is stay close to home
waiting and hoping for a life to return
to normal
Al Jazeera spoke to Sudanese Army Chief
Abdul fatal now he says the country
doesn't need outside interference and
the conflict will be solved by Sudanese
people
we need to decrease the Dilemma of
violence we need to make sure fighting
doesn't occur in residential areas to
avoid civilian casualties we need the
leaders of the rapid support forces to
understand their position to stay
outside the cities and residential areas
we do not need any International or
Regional interference because we as
Sudanese people will reach a point that
satisfies us
now the rapid support forces leader
Muhammad hamdan dagalo told the
financial times that we're ready for
General burhan to hit us but not the
civilians we asked God that we gain
control and arrest him to hand him over
to Justice Bergen and his gang of
islamists came into power and are not
willing to let go